Okay
on
to more trait
conscientiousness.
Conscientiousness is a good predictor of
longterm life success.
It's a good predictor negatively of
divorce.
So I'm more conscientious.
People are less likely to get divorced.
It's a really good predictor of grades.
It's a decent predictor of income.
It's a good predictor of social status,
eventual social status.
It seems to be particularly good at
predicting
outcomes for people who are engaged in
managerial administrative and process
management occupations.
And so all of those occupations are
characterized by the necessity of
reliability,
integrity,
and um,
attention to detail.
It's not associated with creativity,
right?
That's openness.
So the open people are better artists
and entrepreneurs by all appearances.
So
all together conscientiousness seems to
be relatively positive trait.
And so then you might wonder why there
was a distribution,
right?
Like why isn't everybody hyper
conscientious?
Well,
it appears at least in part that as with
all the other personality dimensions,
there's increasing price to be paid as
you deviate from the average.
And so unconscientious people,
they tend to rely on others to support
them.
They're not particularly ambitious or
reliable.
Okay.
But they're not particularly rigid
either.
And so one possibility might be that low
levels of conscientiousness are an asset
at certain times when combined with
other traits.
So for example,
the data isn't all in on this yet,
but it seems to me quite likely that
orderliness,
which is an aspect of conscientiousness,
conscientiousness breaks down into
orderliness and industriousness and
those actually seem to be importantly
different.
I think orderliness probably puts an
additional constraint on creativity.
No.
So we've studied entrepreneurs for a
long time and uh,
it's clear that higher levels of
orderliness certainly aren't associated
with entrepreneur entrepreneurial
capacity.
And I have the sneaking suspicion that
that's because you know,
orderly people are very concerned with
doing whatever needs to be done in the
particular way that it's supposed to be
done.
And the with that is,
is that if you're a creative,
so if you're engaged in a creative
enterprise,
the thing flips around on you a lot.
Like there's a lot of transformations as
you're moving towards the end and that's
not exactly something in orderly person
is going to appreciate.
I also suspect that orderly people are
likely to,
there are two likely to obey rules to be
entrepreneurial or creative.
Now obviously obeying rules has its
utility,
right?
But it doesn't,
when the rules are wrong or when they
start to interfere with something that
might be conceptualized as higher a
higher value than the rules themselves.
For conscientious people,
it's not self evident that there are
more important values than following the
rules and doing things properly.
And so,
you know,
that's part of what makes them reliable
workers and decent citizens and all of
that sort of thing.
It's also partly what tips them towards
conservatism on the political spectrum.
So the best predictors of political
conservatism are low openness and high
conscientiousness,
particularly orderliness.
So actually liberals and conservatives
don't seem to be much different than one
another in terms of industriousness,
but they're quite markedly different in
terms of orderliness or,
you know,
you could say,
well,
what predicts liberalism is high
openness and low conscientiousness,
particularly orderliness,
uh,
because you don't necessarily have to
just be predicting con conservatism.
So
now
you remember the big two model.
So conscientiousness lumps in with
emotional stability and agreeableness to
produce stability.
And as people age,
they become more stable,
they become more conscientious,
more emotionally stable and more
agreeable.
And you know,
you probably interpret that somewhat
pleasantly as an improvement in
maturity.
So,
and conscientiousness is quite highly
correlated with neuroticism negatively.
So it turns out generally speaking,
that the more conscientious you are,
the less neurotic you are.
And we,
we think that that might be actually
because of the tendency of
conscientiousness as a trait manifested
across time to stabilize environments.
You know,
so if you're a conscientious person,
imagine that because you're
conscientious,
but not perfectionistic.
Let's say you stay on top of your
homework and you get your assignments
done,
let's even say ahead of time.
Well,
partly what that means is that the
amount that you have to worry about how
you're going to be doing decreases.
And of course if you're conscientious
and over time your field of
opportunities opens up from an
employment perspective,
plus your income increases and you've
stabilized the environment around you.
And so there's less uncertainty in it
and more security.
And so,
you know,
it could easily be that
conscientiousness has its effect on
neuroticism,
stabilizing the environment,
taking the uncertainty out of it,
and then making people not so much
really less like lower in neuroticism
but just less likely to be anxious and
in emotional pain in general.
So,
so here's some distinctions between
orderliness and industriousness.
You guys can decide where you fit on
these.
So if you're orderly,
you don't leave your belongings around
you like order,
that's I'm surprised at one,
you keep things tidy,
you follow a schedule,
okay,
you're bothered by messy people.
You want everything to be just right.
You're bothered by disorder,
you don't,
you,
you like routine,
you see that rules are observed and you
want every detail taken care of.
So the other thing you can kind of
understand likely is the door.
To me,
people aren't that much fun,
you know?
And I also think that's relevant because
you know,
people have different kinds of social
value,
right?
And sometimes you value people because
of their ability to contribute,
perhaps from an economic perspective
because they're hard workers and they're
productive.
But you know,
when you think about Comedians,
comedians have a fairly high social
value as far as I'm concerned,
but the probability that they're orderly
as a class is pretty much zero.
It was,
people are high in high in extroversion,
clearly low in agreeableness,
generally speaking,
because you're just not going to make
rude comments about people to get alive,
which is what comedians do.
At least 50% of the time unless you're
disagreeable and they have to be pretty
low in conscientiousness because like
really a conscientious comedian,
is this just not going to happen?
The lifestyle doesn't lend itself to
that,
right?
I mean,
it's erratic.
Your employment is going to be erratic.
The probability that you're going to be
regularly employed is low.
You're up at night all the time.
You're always partying because that
would go,
that's the meal you,
that you're in,
you know?
Um,
and then you might,
you know,
you might think the same about people
who are artistic performers,
like musicians.
You know,
if you want to be a rock musician for
example,
when you're a teenager,
of course that makes you just a typical
teenager in some ways.
But if you're going to pursue that into
adulthood,
there's a lot of many more stable
occupations that you have to forego.
You know,
when you have to be willing to adopt the
route of erratic and unpredictable
lifestyle that would go along with being
say a traveling musician.
And that also has to not make you feel
bad.
And you know,
we don't exactly know what makes people
industrious or,
or conscientious,
but avoiding feeling bad seems to be
some seems to have something to do with
it except that it's complicated.
They,
because the hypothesis fundamentally
behind the big five traits analysis is
that all the negative emotions load
together on a single factor,
right?
So that's fundamentally neuroticism.
So then you might say,
well,
if it's neuroticism that all the
negative emotions are loading on what's
left over for the conscientious people
to use to feel bad with.
And we think that conscientiousness
isn't a well understood dementia.
Like it's understood from a measurement
perspective,
we can measure it quite accurately,
but mostly only using questionnaires,
either self report or other persons a
report.
We don't have any direct measures of
industriousness and so and so that's
kind of strange because it's such a
potent phenomena that you think that you
could come up with lab tasks that
industrious people for example,
would do a better job that than non
industrious people,
but we haven't been able to identify one
and we probably screamed 50 years,
50 to 75 different tasks,
never got any effect at all.
With orderliness though,
we've had more luck because what
orderliness seems to be associated with,
although not overwhelmingly powerfully,
is disgust,
sensitivity and so discussed seems to be
an emotional axis that's distinct to
some degree from neuroticism.
And you know,
you might say,
well,
the disgusting things,
if you're too close to a disgusting
thing,
you'd also get anxious.
And I think that's probably true,
but the emotion of disgust isn't the
same as the emotion of anxiety or the
emotion of pain.
Disgust is a revulsion emotion.
It's a getaway from me emotion.
Sometimes it's an emotion that will
elicit anger,
defensive anger,
to push something disgusting the way or
to be contemptuous of it or to roll your
eyes at it.
Now,
here's an interesting little fact.
One of the best predictors of impending
divorce is eye rolling.
So if you have a couple in therapy and
you notice that when one talks,
the other rolls their eyes,
you know that that's just not very good.
So that's something to remember in your
own relationships.
If you're starting to roll your eyes at
your partner,
you might think,
well,
that's a contemporary response.
That's a disgust response if you're
starting to do that,
that it's either time to stop or time to
start looking for a new partner.
So
now the orderliness discussed connection
turns out to be theoretically extremely
interesting,
and we're going to talk about that in
some detail as we move forward.
But I'll go through industriousness
next.
And so an industrious person carries out
their plans.
Now that might be the critical element
of industriousness.
So if you look at the general
neuropsychological literature,
what you generally derived from that is
that the prefrontal cortex is involved
in behavioral regulation because the
prefrontal Cortex is the,
is the part of the brain that people use
to generate plans.
And dorsolateral prefrontal cortical
function is primarily cognitive,
at least in so far as we've been able to
measure it.
And the cognitive abilities of the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex appear
to be quite tightly linked to fluid
intelligence as we discussed before.
And so it also stands to reason to some
degree that your ability to plan and
your intelligence might be associated
with your ability to carry out your
plans are not to waste time.
The cortex overall has been viewed as an
organ that inhibits impulsivity.
You know,
but as we've discussed,
the idea that impulsivity is inhibited
is probably not the world's most
sophisticated idea.
It's probably more that impulsivity is
unnecessary if you've developed a
sufficiently sophisticated personality
because you can get what you need to
have through more complex and
sophisticated means with less social
conflict.
But anyways,
there's this idea that's been maintained
in the neuropsychological literature for
a very long time,
that the ability to plan is associated
with increased control over impulsivity.
But the problem with that theory is that
it doesn't seem to be true.
So there's no correlation.
The correlation between intelligence and
industriousness is zero.
And that's weird because man,
if you take intelligence and correlate
it with something,
it's correlated with almost everything,
you know.
So even disgust sensitivity if,
if we measured this test sensitivity and
there's a variety of ways of doing that.
What we find is more intelligent,
people are less disgust sensitive.
So even,
and you know,
the connection there is by no means
obvious,
right?
Because you could just as easily think
that intelligent people would be less or
it would be more disgusted sensitive.
But that hasn't,
that isn't how it is now.
The idea of carrying out your plans,
that's an interesting one because
imagine,
think about what cognition is like,
especially abstract cognition of the
kind that we were talking about last,
last,
uh,
last class.
In order to abstract,
you have to separate the objects of your
internal manipulation from the world,
right?
So here,
here's an example.
So when you go to sleep at night,
there's a little switch,
for lack of a better term,
that shuts your body down.
And so what happens is that when you're
dreaming,
of course you're dreaming about running
around and you move your eyes while
you're dreaming.
Now it turns out that the motor systems
that control your eyes aren't shutdown
because who cares?
You can move your eyes and still be in
bed asleep,
not running around in your dream.
But if you take a cat or another animal
and you destroy that off,
switch the capitol run around and act
out its dreams,
okay?
So it's thinking is linked to its
behavior.
So integrity that when it runs a
simulation,
it's going to act it out.
Now,
human beings don't do that.
What happens when we think or we often
don't do that?
There are times when we can avoid doing
that.
You know,
when you think you sit there,
you generate up your world of
abstraction,
you have your abstract representations
and you manipulate them.
And so you might think,
well this is what I'm going to do to
tomorrow.
You run a simulation in your head,
but you wouldn't be able to do that if
you couldn't pull the simulated you away
from the actual view,
right?
You have to divorce the representation
from the thing it's representing in
order to manipulate it abstractly.
So that opens up the possibility that
you can think through things perfectly
well without ever enacting your plans.
And that's actually what you see in the
therapeutic realm.
If you have a client who's
unconscientious,
you've got a real problem because the
person won't do anything that they say
they're going to do.
And so,
you know,
generally speaking,
especially for behavioral therapy,
what happens is that someone will come
in with a problem and you discuss an
array of potential solutions and you
know,
an intelligent person could do that
better than an unintelligent person.
And then you decide which of those
potential solutions might be
implemented.
And then you wait,
you know,
you don't want to put too much of a
burden on the person because you want to
make the probability that they'll
actually implement the change very high.
So you do it quite slowly because people
aren't that good at implementing
behavioral changes.
And then,
you know,
hopefully the person comes back and
says,
well,
I've tried this and here's the outcome,
and then you modify it accordingly.
It's got,
it's called essentially called
collaborative empiricism.
Um,
but the problem with doing that with
someone who's unconscientious is that
they'll come back and they'll say,
well,
I didn't get around to it.
It's like,
okay,
well what are you supposed to do about
that?
It's like if the person doesn't get
around to doing things,
that'll help.
How can you get them to get around to
doing anything that'll help?
It's,
it's one of those flaws that seems to
interfere with the process itself.
You know?
Now I could say,
well,
maybe you could make the person
enthusiastic about it and they'd be
driven by enthusiasm,
which is more of a positive emotion.
Or maybe you could terrify them half to
death by the negative consequences of
not doing it,
which is also useful.
Or maybe they're agreeable and so they'd
be willing to do it for someone else.
Like there's other places or if they're
open,
you can think of a creative way to do
it.
There's other places you can get
leverage,
but without the conscientiousness
there's a real problem.
It's really,
it's really difficult.
Okay.
So industriousness seems to be
associated with the ability or the
willingness.
God only knows to take plans that are
formulated and then to implement them
into behavior in [inaudible],
the voluntarily into behavior and you
know,
everyone knows that's a relatively
difficult thing to do.
You know,
if you're trying to settle yourself down
to do a task,
especially when you don't want to do so,
you're not enthusiastic about it.
Right.
That can't carry you.
Do you want to settle down and do a task
that you're not enthusiastic about?
That takes effort?
You know,
you could say it takes willpower.
And I actually think the conscientious
person,
especially,
I think especially the orderly person,
is an addict,
is a person who admires willpower.
And that seems to be associated with
something like due to fullness as a,
as a moral construct.
So a conscientious person will do
something because they should do it or
because they have a duty to do it.
And that's partly also why you see
conscientiousness as an element of
conservatism.
Because conservatives tend to be more
patriotic,
for example,
and they are more willing to think of
their moral obligation in terms of
service to the structured community.
Now we just did a factor analysis of
conservative belief,
conservative versus liberal belief.
And one of my students is presenting
that for her phd defense.
We took a long time to do it about four
years to really get the measures down.
And you know,
you hear about social conservative than
fiscal social conservatism and fiscal
conservatism,
right?
So the social conservatives,
conservatives are usually in the,
in the states,
they're prolife,
they're,
um,
they're usually not fans of gay
marriage.
They're,
they're,
you know,
they're not advocates.
Generally speaking of a welfare state,
they're against single parent families
or that,
you know,
so that's all social conservative.
It's,
it's like a moral,
it's a moral dimension of belief.
Whereas fiscal conservativism is
something like don't run deficits,
you know,
if you want it to put it,
simply don't spend,
the government shouldn't spend any more
money a than it has.
And so that's an important principle.
But it also isn't an agent of economic
development.
It's not really seen that way.
They're more like minimal government
people,
but we got no evidence for a split
between fiscal and social conservatism.
So I don't think it exists.
I think it's just a media invention
because we did construct validation of
the sort that I've been talking to you
about.
What we got instead were three factors.
We got masculine independence.
That's what we decided to call it
because it was much more common among
men.
And it kind of looked like
libertarianism,
which is a brand of conservatism,
which is basically you go and do your
bloody thing and I'll do my thing and
we'll either leave each other alone or
if we don't,
we'll compete and one of us can win and
that'll be just fine.
So it looked like,
so one of the things that's interesting
about that,
and it really got me thinking was that,
you know,
that classic explanation for why
Conservatives are conservative is
because they're afraid of,
they're afraid,
but there's just no evidence for that.
Conservatives are less neurotic than
liberals by a substantial margin.
And you know,
there is evidence that they have a
negativity bias,
which I don't really want to explain,
but what that means sometimes is that
they'll actually pay more attention to
negative information rather than less in
comparison to liberal.
So what it means is not clear,
but the masculine independence dimension
is a very interesting one because it
implies that there's a reason for
hierarchy beyond structure.
You can't win unless you play a
structure game.
So you know what a lot of what the
masculine,
independent types want is they want to
say just get the damn rules straight.
I don't really care what they are,
but if you get them straight,
all follow them.
But that'll so hierarchy because that,
you know,
as soon as you,
it's approved,
produced a value structure,
you produce a hierarchy because people
compete towards fulfilling the,
you know,
they compete towards the end game and
that'll immediately produced a hierarchy
out of,
uh,
accomplishment,
let's say.
And then you might say,
well,
why would men be particularly motivated
to do that?
And the answer seems to be because of
hyper gummy and hypergo b is the
tendency of women to make across her up
dominance hierarchies.
So the males compete with one another
and they want to because they want to
win.
[inaudible] and part of the consequence
of winning is that they have much more
success with women.
And that's a primary motivator.
So,
so that's interesting because it,
it,
it provides a rationale for supporting a
relatively structured hierarchy that has
nothing to do with,
with,
you know,
having to deal with the negative
consequences of not having a stable
worldview.
It's more,
and you know,
there's another thing to think about to
hear with regards to hierarchies.
It's like
if you have an ideal,
you immediately have a hierarch.
So if you,
because of course let's say that you
have a bunch of children and gymnasium
and you say,
well let's do somersaults to the other
side of the wall.
You know,
there's an implication there and the
implication is that you can be better or
worse at it.
So the kids will immediately compete,
especially the boys immediately compete
to roll to the other side of the wall as
fast as they possibly can.
And so if you want it to get rid of
hierarchy,
you'd have to get rid of values.
And that seems like a really stupid
thing to do to me,
you know,
because without values,
you have no positive motivation because
you feel almost all your positive
motivation in relationship to a goal.
Right?
Because it's not attainment of the goal
that makes people happy.
Generally speaking,
it's observation of the fact that their
efforts are contributing to them moving
towards a value goal.
So,
okay,
so there's masculine and independence.
That was one dimension.
Another dimension was basically
religious traditionalism.
And then there was more women who were
aligned with that,
which was interesting because we found
more women on the far left of the
spectrum too,
which I'll talk about in a minute.
So,
and then the last one was something like
ethnocentrism,
which is like,
you know,
if you're not like us,
go away basically.
And so,
but none of those were fiscal,
social or none of them.
None of those were fiscal or social.
So that was quite interesting.
And it also shows you the utility of
getting your measurements right.
Because if you don't get your
measurements right,
you don't even know what you're talking
about.
And conservatism characterized along
those three dimensions is a lot
different than conservative as in
characterized as fiscal versus social.
They're not the same phenomenon.
So,
okay.
So back to the industrious person
carries out his or her plants wastes
time.
Negative con industrious people don't
waste time.
So they stay,
they stay focused on their goal or they,
they continue acting in relationship to
the goal that's more accurate.
Finds it difficult to get down to work.
No,
that isn't characteristic of industrious
people.
And you can see the willpower element to
that to some degree.
You know,
you can tell yourself to sit down and
work and you will so messes things up.
No,
that isn't what an industrious person
does.
Finishes what he or she starts.
Yes.
Puts his or her mind on the task at
hand.
So there seems to be an intentional
phenomena there,
right?
Is the person is able to focus in
without distractions.
Um,
gets things done quickly.
Well industrious people seem to be fans
of efficiency and you can kind of see
the relationship between efficiency in
order.
Although you can also see at times where
the demand for more efficiency would
require the disruption of a,
of something that was previously
orderly.
So an industrious person and an orderly
person might have a,
you know,
a dispute about that always knows what
he or she is doing.
So that's again,
there's a kind of certainty and
direction that's associated with that
doesn't postpone decisions,
isn't easily distract and orderliness is
the big predictor of longterm life
success.
Now orderliness is more predictive of
success in jobs that require careful
attention to the management of process
so that if something has become
something has been turned into an
algorithm.
So that means there's a process by which
it might be done.
Then in order to be a person is very
good at making sure that the,
that uh,
you know that,
that the algorithm runs exactly as it's
supposed to without error.
You see,
conscientiousness actually has quite a
good predictor of scientific
productivity because one of the things
that science does in large part is
reduce the reliance on intelligence and
increase the reliance on
conscientiousness.
I mean that's one of its powers,
right?
Because you can be a not spectacularly
bright scientists,
but if you're good at methodology and
you're detail oriented and you know the
literature,
you can figure out what the next problem
is to solve what's micro problem.
Cause you know where the problems are.
And then science is like a,
almost like a meat grinder.
You know,
if you turn the crank property,
you feed in raw information,
you turn the crank property,
you're going to make the next,
you know,
tiny step forward.
So it's maybe the more open scientists
to leap way the hell into the future and
completely transform a field at the
level of fundamental presupposition.
But most of the scientists are just
nibbling on the edges between order and
chaos.
And you know,
it's a whole monstrous,
massive,
the moving forward tiny amounts at once.
And so that's partly what makes science
extremely powerful.
Okay.
We don't know why people are
industrious,
we can't figure it out.
I have a sneaking suspicion I told you
that maybe part of it is that they want
to win within a defined framework and
then that might be associated with
hyperglycemia.
Now one of the things you see is that
there is a gender difference between men
and women in relationship to
conscientiousness,
not conscientiousness overall,
but women are more orderly than men and
men are more industrious than women.
And that kind of goes along with the
hyper gummy.
So you remember high pergamum he has
this tendency that I described already.
It's the case had many,
many among many,
many types of creature.
Um,
so there might be that as a motivation,
although I don't,
I don't think that you can simply say
that men think that if they get
successful,
they're going to have more luck with
women.
Although that's certainly a conscious
realization on the part of many men.
I think it's such a deep phenomena
though that it's bill,
it's more like it's built into the
motivational system a priority,
you know,
so anyways,
so that would go on the masculine
independence front.
But,
but we still haven't been able to
manipulate that with any,
to any great degree.
Maybe we're thinking as well that what
conscientious people are doing is not so
much striving to get to the talk as they
are trying really hard to stay away from
the bottom and now would go along with
the,
with the orderliness,
industriousness overlap,
you know,
say if,
if,
um,
part of what makes you orderly and
somewhat industrious is disgust,
sensitivity.
One of the things that you might want to
do is flee from the bottom of dominance
hierarchies because the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy is a bad place to be
from the perspective of maintenance of
health.
Like people at the bottom of dominance,
hierarchies are generally speaking in
much rougher shape than the people who
are closer to the talk.
And so part of being industriousness
might want,
might be maybe you're motivated by not
wanting to fail and then you might
think,
well that's anxiety,
but maybe not,
you know,
conscientious people.
Let's say you have someone walking down
the street and they encounter a homeless
person.
Okay.
Is a conscientious person more or less
likely to give the conscientious person
money or give the homeless person to
give the homeless person money?
What do you think?
No,
that's right.
No agreeable person that they'll give
the person money.
The conscientious first and especially
the,
wasn't that sort of hyper orderly or say
get a job.
And they do that because conscientious
people are also more judgmental.
And that goes along with,
with,
uh,
the hierarchical attitude.
I think they,
you know,
they genuinely run on the principal,
but being higher up in the hierarchy is
better and that there's something wrong
with you from a moral perspective if you
happen to be,
you know,
among the failures.
And so one possibility is that part of
the reason that conscientious people,
industrious people are that way is
because they judge themselves quite
harshly and they really do not want to
fail.
But it's not because they're anxious,
it's because they're disgusted self
disgusted by the possibility that they
might count among the failures.
And so that grounded it in an entirely
different motivational system.
So now there's some other things about
how about conscientiousness that are
pretty interesting.
I think they're kind of revolutionarily.
Interesting.
So the first thing I told you was that
overall,
especially for industries,
to us,
we have no theoretical model,
no neuropsychological bottle,
no psychological model and no
pharmacological model.
I could add to that no animal model.
So that's pretty damn weird because
pretty,
pretty.
Almost always when you discover
something psychometrically and it's
stable,
you can start connecting it to other
things that you've discovered.
Like,
you know,
extroversion is associated with
incentive reward and neuroticism is
associated with the anxiety systems and
you know,
stability looks like it's associated
with higher levels of Serotonin and
openness looks like it's associated with
decreased latent inhibition.
Like we know we've got some insight into
what's going on at other levels of
analysis with regards to these traits.
Conscientiousness,
no,
except for this connection between
orderliness and discussed.
Yes.
He's like,
well that's a good question.
Are there conscientious animals?
You know,
that's a tough one.
You might say yes because sled dogs and
that sort of thing and,
and like Australian blue heelers,
first of all,
they're super intelligence.
So that is something to take into
account.
But they also really seem to like to
work.
But I would say they're probably more
enthusiastic than conscientious,
you know,
cause they love to work.
They're out,
they're wagging their tail.
It's like that's not what you're doing
when you're doing telephone sales.
You know?
So yeah,
but
like sort of like this idea of some kind
of value,
more gentlemen indicted in Ibm.
So I don't think animals has this kind
of,
whenever more rude.
Well,
it's not obvious like,
because if you look at chimpanzees,
for example,
um,
the chimpanzees and other primates,
they have pretty stable dominance
hierarchies there actually hereditary
and the,
the top primates are pretty rough on the
bottom primates and a lot of it looks
like contempt.
So,
you know,
because what else would it be?
Exactly.
You know.
But by the same token,
it's not that easy to generate an animal
model of disgust.
That's another problem.
Well,
I mean,
you think about dogs,
those bloody things,
they're not disgusted by anything.
You know,
they're enthusiastic about lots of
things that no,
nothing in its right mind should ever be
enthusiastic about.
So anyway,
so,
okay,
so
all right.
So overall,
if you're conscientious,
you're going to be more satisfied with
your life,
especially as you've progressed through
time and you're going to be more,
more happy,
you're going to be happier.
Which is funny because of course
happiness is basically extroversion.
So you might ask what does that have to
do with conscientiousness?
But what it seems to happen is that
because of your conscientious across
time,
your life actually stabilizes and gets
better.
And so even though you might not be more
happy,
you'll be less miserable.
And they'll tell you if you give people
a choice between les miserable and
happier,
they'll take less miserable because it's
really painful to be miserable.
But it's only so it's only moderately
good to be happy.
We have a much bigger capacity for
negative emotion then for positive
emotion.
So it's positively related to life
satisfaction and happiness,
but it's also positively related to
depression.
Conscientious people are more likely to
get depressed now.
So there's part of the reason why there
might be some variation.
Conscientiousness.
So you might say,
well conscientious people do really well
when they're fully employed,
but if you fire someone who's
conscientious,
they do not have a good time with it
because the judgmental part of their
personality starts to wreak havoc with
themselves.
You know,
because their attitude is if you work
hard,
you can get ahead.
Right?
And so that's an index.
Your success is an index of your moral
value,
essentially.
Well,
so then you lose your,
your employment.
What the hell are you supposed to
conclude?
Well,
you couldn't conclude that the whole
system is rotten,
but you're very unlikely to do that if
you're conscientious cause you're sort
of a patriotic type and,
and you know,
you,
you are,
you identify quite strongly with the
structure of the system.
And plus,
you know,
conscientious people are very concerned
with justice and they might think,
well,
if I'm going to have this attitude
towards other people who failed,
you know,
who are unemployed,
let's say I have to have the same
attitude towards me.
And so what you see with conscientious
people,
if they're having,
you know,
maybe they've got laid off at work
really through absolutely no fault of
their own,
they are just torn up by it because one
of the things they do that's different
for an unconscientious first and
everything is always someone else's
fault.
But for a conscientious person,
it's the opposite.
And everything is always their fault.
Well,
the problem,
there's an advantage to that a cause.
If you take responsibility for your
situation,
then there's a possibility that you'll
make whatever changes you can to improve
your situation.
You know?
So even if you're only 10% at fault,
if you take responsibility for that,
then you can fix that 10% and maybe
things will work out better for you.
So you know,
there's some advantages to
overestimating the degree to which
you're at fault.
And if you say,
well,
it's the system,
okay,
good,
fine,
go fix that.
Like it's not going to happen.
So it's not a very effective means of
coping,
but in psychotic depression,
for example,
which is a very,
very extreme form of depression,
what you often see is that the depressed
person erroneously concludes,
it's like a metaphysical conclusion
almost that their faults are integrally
tied to the,
you know,
to everything that happens that's bad in
the world.
And so they take on all of the guilt for
everything that's gone wrong.
And obviously that's,
there's a point at which that's a
relatively counterproductive conclusion,
you know,
especially because often when bad things
happen to you in life,
there's a random element and you know,
you can't really treat yourself properly
unless you take that random element into
account.
Now you can overestimate it,
which is what you do.
If you're under,
I'm unconscientious and you could,
could overestimate it if you're
unconscientious and underestimated,
if you're conscientious and there's
going to be times when you paid for both
of those attitudes.
So anyways,
conscientious people don't do very well
when they're,
when they're not doing very well because
they,
they judge themselves very harshly.
And so that's partly what,
and it's related to guilt.
It's not a hat.
It's a funny thing because there's an
element of guilt that's associated with
conscientiousness too.
So conscientious people feel guilt less
often,
but they're more sensitive to it.
So,
and then you think,
well that's kind of paradoxical.
It's not exactly paradoxical.
If you're sensitive to guilt,
you might arrange things so that you
have nothing to feel guilty about.
And that's what conscientious people
seem to do.
And so guilt,
guilt and shame seemed to be emotions
that are integrity associated with
conscientiousness and they're kind of
difficult to disentangle it,
you know?
And maybe they're not even really
separate things.
But shame seems to be something that you
feel when you fail,
perhaps in the eyes of others.
And guilt is something that you feel
when you fail according to your own
standards.
And I know that that's kind of a messy
definition,
but conscientious people do seem to be
more prone to shame and guilt.
And those seem to be in principle
mediated by different systems than the
systems that mediate anxiety and
emotional pain.
But we don't know what the systems are.
Now you can also think about it
in relationship to something,
you know what to what the
existentialists called,
like the existential burden.
So you know,
people are always doing things in
groups.
The groups are often oriented to,
to produce a certain outcome,
like a hunting party.
We could say that if we're thinking of
it from an evolutionary perspective,
like there's it,
there's a goal and it's an important
goal and they're going to be good
hunters and hundreds of that aren't so
good.
And
part of the way,
and this is to think of a hierarchy as
something other than a dominance
hierarchy because the dominance
hierarchy theory is slightly flawed
because it implies that the hierarchy is
only based on power.
Right?
But that's not right.
Like if you have a hunting party or a
building crew or anything like that,
a lot of what elevates one man above the
other in the dominance hierarchy isn't
power.
It's competence,
you know?
So the best hunter has the highest
reputation or the best builder has the
highest reputation or you know,
it depends on what the hierarchy is
devoted for,
but the person who's best at that rises
to the top,
you know,
all other things being equal.
And that's often the case.
Even if people don't like them very
much.
You know,
we've done investigations into corporate
structures where someone will be
approved by a relatively large majority
of the people who worked for the company
because they're hyper competent,
but no one really likes,
you know?
And so you can't really think of that
as,
as you know,
either a popularity contest or something
that's based on power.
And I think that a decent hierarchies
almost never based on power,
based on competence.
Now those two things get tangled up,
but well,
so then you think one of the things
that's going to make people
prone to being successful is to feel
some responsibility in relationship to
their capacity to attain a goal in a
group situation.
And I think that's partly the origin of
both conscientiousness and guilt and
shame.
You know,
lots of times if you talk to unemployed
people and you know we hear a lot about
rates of depression and that sort of
thing,
but what kind of boneheaded about the
way we measure things?
Like if you want to be depressed,
the best thing to do is lose your job.
And then you really got to ask yourself,
are you depressed or are you unemployed?
You know,
those aren't the same thing.
You know?
And you might say,
well for some people unemployment
doesn't make them depressed.
It's like,
well,
we know that that's the unconscientious
people or maybe the unconscientious
people and the emotionally stable
people,
something like that.
But for the people who are conscientious
and also maybe somewhat neurotic man
that's just going to wipe them out.
But to think about that as psychological
is rather foolish.
You know,
it's,
it's an actual loss and they're
responding to it in an actual way.
And so,
you know,
and usually people who are unemployed,
I mean part of the reason that they get
depressed is because they're worried
about their future,
you know?
But that's not the only reason.
What they often talk about is that
they've let people down.
So that'd be people in their family or
they let themselves down or they're
performing underneath their capacity or
they're just useless and aren't
contributing.
And those are all places where,
you know,
their guilt will start to eat them up.
And those are the sorts of things that
seem also to be associated with
conscientiousness.
It's like the idea that you know,
you're part of a team of sled dogs in
your,
you have a responsibility to pull your
weight and if you're not pulling your
weight,
then there's something contemptible
about you.
And if you happen to be one of those
people who aren't pulling their weight,
then there's something contemptible
about you,
even if it's you making the judgment.
So and conscientious people are
definitely more judgmental.
So for example,
if you read them,
if you tell them stories about people
who performed various criminal and cause
I criminal acts and you get them to
estimate the sentence that they should
be subjected to the conscientious people
will reliably,
you know,
put people in prison for longer periods
of time.
They don't like violations of,
they don't like violations of norms or
violations of rules and so and so,
you know,
so one of the reasons that people might
bet there might be a distribution and
conscientiousness is like maybe when the
whole economy collapses,
which happens fairly frequently,
the conscientious people just wipe
themselves out.
You know,
they're so depressed and so self
judgemental and so crushed that they
can't handle the,
that you know,
the,
what would you call that?
That's the very,
yeah,
it's variability.
That's not the word I was looking for.
So they get clipped off when things
fail.
Co I'm conscientious person doesn't
really care.
And that's actually sort of almost like
the defining characteristic of an
unconscientious person is they don't
really care.
And that's an interesting thing too,
because it's often more fun to be around
unconscientious people than it is to be,
you're unconscientious people because
it's very hard to relax around people
who are really orderly and judgmental.
You know,
you can't even sit improperly or you get
judged for it.
Whereas if you're in someone's house and
they're unconscientious,
you know,
and you throw your beer can on the
floor,
they'll just laugh and throw their beer
camera,
you know?
And so that's,
I think it's difficult to relax with,
with really hyper conscientious people.
It's probably difficult to have fun with
them.
I think it's difficult for them to
relax.
You know,
they,
they tend like conservative people tend
to read less,
you know?
And you might think,
well,
that might be associated with their
interest in intellectual activity
because they're also lower and openness.
But I think it's also because they
regard reading as a waste of time,
not because they exactly regard reading
as a waste of time,
but they feel guilty if they're not
working and instead they're sitting down
reading of us,
what are you doing sitting down reading
a book?
You know,
there's work to be done.
And so they're very work oriented.
So,
okay,
orderliness is a good predictor of
conservatism,
as we've already said.
And it's associated with disgust,
sensitivity,
and preference for order and tradition,
not egalitarianism.
So then you think,
well,
where's the egalitarian motivations?
And they all seem to pile up pretty much
on agreeableness.
So the conscientious people basically
say,
you can get ahead if you play the game
properly and you abide by the rules that
and you work.
And the agreeable people say,
well,
yeah,
but there's lots of people who can't
really manage that.
And you know,
we're not just going to push them off a
cliff.
They need to be taken care of.
And you know,
the situation wasn't fair to begin with.
You know,
and,
and there's a battle between that all
the time.
And there's a battle because
agreeableness and conscientiousness are
orthogonal,
which means that they actually traverse
different ethics,
right?
And they're not opposites on the
continuum,
conscientiousness and agreeableness.
That's not it at all.
So,
and it looks like in order for,
you know,
in order for people to adjust to the
world of human beings,
you have to be agreeable to some measure
and you have to be conscientious to some
measure.
And the question is how much of each,
and the answer is,
well it depends on the circumstances and
where you place yourself.
But at the same question applies to the,
to the polity at large,
how agreeable should it be versus how
conscientious should it be?
And that's a very,
very,
it's,
it's not a problem with a solution.
The solution is only to be derived from
a continual dialogue say between the
conscientious people and the agreeable
people.
Because the answer varies as the
environment varies.
So you can't come up with an end
solution to that problem.
So,
okay.
You know,
the conscientious people,
so we'll say the conservatives for
there,
for the sake of argument,
they liked hierarchies.
They like order,
they like a game that everyone can play
and some people can win and they make
the assumption that if you play properly
and you win,
but that,
that you've done something good.
Well,
the problem is is that if you steepen up
the hierarchy enough,
no one gets to climb it and then the
whole bloody society starts to crumble
and breakdown because the rates of
violence go way up.
So you can see there's a,
there's an upper bound to the steepness
of a hierarchy.
And so you might say,
well,
that's where conscientiousness hits
limit hits its limit.
Or You could even say that's where merit
meritocracy hypothetically hits its
limit.
Because you know,
if you're intelligent and conscientious,
you're much more likely to rise to the
top of a hierarchy.
Well,
fine.
Maybe you want smart,
hardworking people at the top of
structures.
But if,
if it's steep like this,
well then,
okay,
there's a point at which that isn't
sustainable.
And so the hierarchy has to be flat and
somehow,
you know,
no one.
But the problem is,
and that's also something that agreeable
people would say right off the bat.
It's like,
what about the strata at the bottom or
just above the bottom?
How are you going to ensure that they
don't fall right out of the game
altogether,
which is a perfectly reasonable,
a reasonable question and answer to
that,
both those questions as well.
We don't know how to do that.
And so we're trying to solve that
problem continually as we go along.
So orderly people also have harsh
judgments and moral transgressions.
We talked about that.
Now there's an idea of a behavioral
immune system here.
Now this is a cool,
cool
idea.
So disgust is considered to be one of
the basic human emotions defined by a
strong repulsion and desire to withdraw
from and the listening stimulus or event
physically disgust as a company by a
distinct facial expression involving
constriction of the oral and nasal
cavities.
So it's something like that to close
yourself off.
Evolutionary of people make that face
when they hear a dirty joke that they're
really quite offended by evolutionary
models of disgust.
Propose that it's emotion helped to
evolve,
evolve to help us avoid contaminated or
harmful foods or other potential sources
of disease such as sexual contact.
Now that's interesting.
You know,
because there's also an idea that floats
around the general culture and I think
it's be more elaborated upon partly
since the time of Freud by particularly
since the 60s that sexual disgust is
culturally produced.
It's like you can just drop that idea.
It's not the case at all any more than
discussed related to food is culturally
produced,
cultural moves it.
But the disgust response to sexual
contact and to food is extremely,
uh,
powerful innately.
And you know that because otherwise
everyone would always be sleeping with
everyone else.
Like there has to,
because obviously sexual contact is a
primary motivator.
Well,
something has to regulate it and you
might say,
well good sense is what should regulate.
It's like,
yeah,
right man,
good sense,
doesn't regulate good sense,
doesn't regulate anything.
And so there's no way that's going to
happen is the regulator for sexual
behavior.
And that's grounded in contempt and
disgust,
you know?
And we saw a lot of that in the parts of
the crumb video that we watched because
the crumb brothers were always being the
targets of contempt and disgust.
So that's pretty rough.
But you know,
you got to think about why that is too.
It's sexually transmitted.
Diseases are no joke.
You know,
and we don't know how long human beings
have been plagued by them.
But you can presume that it's pretty
much since the beginning of time.
You know,
I mean syphilis was important from the
new world to the old world and was very,
very hard on Europe.
It was one of the reasons that the
victorians were so strict in their
sexual behavior.
The syphilis was a nasty disease until
we've more or less finally brought it
under control.
It's quite susceptible to antibiotics.
And it was,
you know,
transmissible to infants,
which is also a major catastrophe.
And then of course aids,
which was,
you know,
the primary vector for the spread of
aids was promiscuity and the virus
evolved.
Capitalize on promiscuity cause it does
that and you know,
that could easily wiped us out.
Wiped out tens of millions of people.
And so,
you know,
we're pretty smart and got it under
control pretty fast.
But you know,
in some ways it could have easily been
otherwise.
And also AIDS turned out to be not that
easy to catch.
You know,
you actually had to engage in sexual
contact and generally you had to engage
in sexual contact of a relatively
nonstandard type because the,
the most typically used tissues are more
robust to the probability of infection.
So we have any,
any number of,
of,
there's any number of reasons for people
to be disgusted by sexual contact.
So,
and that's something that has to be
contended with in addition to its role
in directly helping to expel harmful
foods from the body.
Discussed also forms an component of the
behavioral immune system,
the suite of psychological mechanisms
that aid in the detection and avoidance
of potential contaminants before they
can make contact with the body.
Yeah,
so there's the immune system,
right?
It attacks invading pathogens,
but there's an analog in your behavior,
which is that you're unlikely to
approach,
touch and consume anything that happens
to be disgusting.
And it's a weird system.
So for example,
um,
people are unlikely to want to touch a
sterilized cockroach.
And I don't mean one that's unable to
breathe,
you know,
I mean one that that's being treated but
heated so that it's free of
contaminants.
People don't like to do that.
They won't eat and this will hardly come
as any surprise.
High quality chocolate molded to
resemble dog feces.
Okay,
so and everyone laughs about that.
Right.
Which is kind of an interesting
response.
So like of course no one would do that
well,
right,
exactly know.
Although you cannot attribute that to
logic,
you can just attribute to the fact that
you know that if you are in that
situation how you would feel and the
first thing you would feel is certainly
not hungry and then turn it off.
Which is an interesting way of thinking
about it.
They,
because it turned off,
it's essentially a sexual expression
turned off and then you'd feel,
I think you'd feel like a moron so to
speak if you ate it right it to yourself
and to anybody who also happened to be
around.
There would be something about self
contamination,
voluntary self contamination there that
would make you appear really not very
admirable or honorable.
It's something like that.
So no,
the question becomes,
and this is where things get tricky,
just exactly what should you be
disgusted,
Bart.
Okay,
so here's another example.
So if you get people to spit into a,
to,
you know,
to put saliva into a cup,
they will not take it back in their
mouth,
don't you think?
Well that's kind of strange too.
It's like,
you know,
with the cup is sterilized,
we'll say,
you know what?
Sterilized while it was just in your
mouth,
like half a second before,
what the Hell is wrong with it now?
And the answer is it's no longer in your
mouth.
And you know,
so there's an,
there's an identification of the
exterior of the body envelope as one of
the things that defines you and not you.
And you know,
the immune system per se,
it was always defining you and not you
getting rid of things that aren't you
and keeping the things that are you.
And that's extended out to our behavior.
So you can get,
here's the sorts of things that Jonathan
Haidt has been,
uh,
discovering hate was really the guy who
did the first major work on discussed.
It's a big deal,
man.
Like two thumbs up for him.
Um,
he's discovered something genuine
inducing disgust responses,
whether via a fall order,
a dis odor,
a disgusting work environment,
or we calling it disgusting experience
led individuals to assign harsher
punishments to others who had committed
moral transgressions.
So that's interesting because what it
also means is that the sense of
discussing,
at least in part,
is that the core of what we might
describe as our desire for justice.
So which we tend to think as a primary,
that cognitive thing,
but most of the things that we do and
hold dear are not primarily cognitive.
They're grounded in,
you know,
phenomena that are deeply embedded
within us.
Harsh moral judgments can even be
induced following the consumption of a
bitter drink.
Well,
poisoning this things are often bitter,
even though bitter things are sometimes
not poisons.
And the bitter flavor evokes,
discussed the same disgust related
facial expressions or observed in
response to unpleasant tastes.
Disgusting photographs and receiving
unfair treatment in an economic game.
So that basically means that if you're
playing,
imagine some kids are playing together
and one of the kids cheats,
or you might say,
well the other kids are going to be
angry,
or they other kids are going to be upset
or the other kids are going to be
anxious because they've upset the
structure of the game.
It's like,
okay,
maybe all those things happen,
but one thing that happens as well as
discussed,
it's like how could you do that?
And then of course if you're disgusting,
the probability that you're going to get
shunted out of the dominance hierarchy
all together,
it's pretty damn high.
Concerns about cleanliness and feelings
of disgust have likewise been related to
political attitudes,
situational reminders of the importance
of physical cleanliness,
such as asking participants to wipe
their hands with antiseptic wipes tends
to increase self-reported political
conservatism.
Such a finding is consistent with the
notion that purity tends to be valued
more highly by conservatives then by
liberals.
Well for much of human history,
female virginity in particular was
highly valued and sometimes the
punishments for deviating from that were
and still can be extraordinarily high.
Well part of the reason why you might
ask why precisely is that,
and part of the reason is an exaggerated
disgust response.
Individuals who report being disgusted
more easily also tend to hold more
conservative political views on topics
including abortion,
gay marriage,
tax cuts,
and affirmative action.
In addition to the effects that have
emerged when using self reported disgust
sensitivity,
more conservative political views have
also been associated with stronger
physiological reactivity to disgusting
images.
Yeah.
So preferences for order and tradition
on the one hand in preferences for
egalitarianism on the other appear to be
taking be related to two core dimensions
of moral value.
So the um,
preferences for order and tradition are
associated with higher levels of
orderliness and
as well as lower levels of openness and
intellect and preferences for
egalitarianism are uniquely associated
with compassion and aspect of
agreeableness.
Political conservatism.
Now this is where the claims get
frightening.
I think political conservatism can be
thought of as a social immune system
reflecting the extension of pathogen
avoidance mechanisms to the integrity of
the social system just as the behavioral
immune system has been conceptualized as
helping to maintain the purity and
integrity of an individual body.
So to me the same pathogen avoidance
system helped me in the abstract
integrity of the social order in
particular to the social immune system
would help to maintain order by
suppressing any actions or individuals
that deviate from a group's accepted
social traditions.
Okay.
Now we're going to make a bit of a segue
here from this.
It has been reported,
for instance,
that that regions with higher levels of
disease prevalence tend to be associated
with higher levels of social conformity
and autocratic rule.
Individuals who feel more vulnerable to
disease likewise report higher levels of
ethnocentrism,
xenophobia,
no,
that's something else to consider.
So,
I don't know if you know this,
but when the Spaniards landed in Central
America,
they had
being from a European population that
was punched and traded in cities,
and the cities were,
from our perspective,
disgusting,
filthy close proximity with animals and
subject to continual waves of epidemic
disease.
Now,
the upside of that for the Europeans was
that all the ones that didn't die
developed immunity to these various
diseases even know,
you know,
I would suspect that over time it was
the majority of people who died from one
epidemic disease or another.
Well,
so then the Spaniards went to the new
world.
Well,
for one reason or another,
there were hardly any epidemic diseases
in North America.
Now,
that was partly because of a relative
dearth of domestic animals and partly
because there weren't as many big
closely packed cities.
But you know,
God only knows what the overall reason
was.
So what happened?
Yeah,
all the native Americans died.
95% of them.
They died from smallpox.
They died from measles.
They died from mumps.
Hey,
guide from chicken pox in successive
waves of epidemic,
demolish mint centered in Central
American rating.
I would all across North American,
South America,
so that by the time the Europeans landed
in,
because the Spaniards got there,
say in the late 14 hundreds right,
early 15 hundreds and so the,
the people who landed at Plymouth Rock,
and that's kind of often what you think
about as the beginning of the European
colonization of North America.
That was like a hundred years later.
Well,
everyone was dead by then.
And their reports that when the,
when the,
when the white settlers,
that religious escapees really landed at
Plymouth Rock,
the data's,
we're happy to see them because there
weren't enough people left bringing in
the crops.
So,
so why am I telling you this?
Well,
and in return syphilis was delivered to
Europe.
At least that's the theory,
although it's not,
you know,
there isn't any certainty about that.
But it seemed to appear at about the
same time.
So the Europeans brought endless numbers
of horrible diseases to the new world
and then the new world returned the
favor with one horrible disease.
But there's a point here,
while I'm still in,
this still happens.
So if you go into the Amazon,
you find your tribe that you know,
hasn't been discovered yet or anywhere
else in the world and you go up and you
shake their hand,
it's like,
that's great,
but they're all dancing like a month.
So,
so why is this important?
Well,
we don't know how often this sort of
thing has happened in the past.
And so it could easily be the case that
part of the reason that people are leery
of people who aren't like them is
because over our evolutionary of the
course of our evolutionary history,
it was at least moderately probable that
you read.
If you ran into another group of people,
even if they didn't kill you and you
immediately went to war,
that the mere contact would devastate
you.
You know?
And you can imagine how that sort of
thing would be attributed to things like
magical power of curses or you know,
whatever have you when people are trying
to strive for an explanation for the
phenomenon.
So that's a nasty little idea.
Now check this out.
Okay.
So this study,
according to a parasite stress
hypothesis,
authoritarian governments are more
likely to emerge in regions
characterized by a high prevalence of
disease causing pathogens.
Recent cross national evidence is
consistent with this hypothesis,
but there are inferential limitations
associated with that evidence.
We report to studies that address some
of these limitations and provide further
tests of the hypothesis.
Study one revealed that parasite
prevalence strongly predicted cross
national differences on measures
assessing individual's authoritarian
personalities and that this affects the
tedious statistically mediated the
relationship between parasite prevalence
and authoritarian governance.
Okay,
so let's unpack that.
What does it mean more disease?
The more the people are authoritarian,
the more the people are authoritarian at
the local level,
at the level of their individual
beliefs,
the more likely the government is to be
authoritarian.
So it's disease,
individual government,
right?
So that's really something
study to tested the parasite stress
hypothesis.
In a sample of traditional small scale
societies,
revolt results revealed that parasite
prevalence predicted measures of
authoritarian governance and did so
evenly when even when statistically
controlling for threats to human
welfare,
what additional threat famine also
uniquely predicted.
Authoritarianism.
Yeah.
But I should also point out that the
historical reasons for famine,
we're often tightly associated with the
historical reasons for disease
prevalence.
So you know,
if you were invaded by rats,
they are going to eat everything that
you produced and the probability that
they're going to bring disease along
with them was pretty damn high.
But look at the correlations together.
These results further substantiate the
parasite stress hypothesis of
authoritarianism and suggested societal
differences in authoritarian governance
result in part from cultural differences
and individual's authoritarian
personalities.
Okay.
What's the correlation between
authoritarian governance and pathogen
prevalence?
Point four to remember what we said
about effect sizes.
That's as powerful an effect as the
relationship between Iq and grades.
It's a whopping effect.
And you know,
there's a lot of error in these
measurements so you can be sure that the
true correlation is higher
famine was also associated with
authoritarian governance.
Um,
so wow,
I read that paper and I thought really,
could that really be the case?
Is that what happens is that,
especially as the incidents of
transmissible diseases increase,
people clamp down on their moral
structures.
They don't let you know.
They don't allow contact between each
between.
They tightened the borders at every
level,
at every level.
Sexual,
personal,
familial,
at the level of the village,
at the level of the state,
they closed the borders.
You know when you can think of the
ultimate border as the surface of your
skin,
you know it is very few people.
There are very few people who believe
that border should be so open that they
don't want control over the border of
their own skin.
And then you might say,
well,
how far out should that be extended in?
The answer to that is,
well,
that's debatable,
but there's obviously a limit on
universality of access and there's
reason for that.
I mean,
there's multiple reasons for it,
but this appears to be one of them.
So you know,
one of the things that indicates,
and this is mind boggling,
who would have guessed this,
is that perhaps the best way to fight
authoritarianism across the world is to
institute effective public health
programs and get rid of the infectious
diseases.
Now who would have guessed that?
But you know,
it,
it makes sense to some degree if,
if the general level of danger and
threat is actually lowered,
maybe people don't have to be so
defensive and you know,
and a judgmental and,
and xenophobic.
You know,
we think often that it's political
argumentation that does this sort of
thing.
But
you know,
there's no malaria in North America.
There's no malaria in Europe.
There was like,
you know,
200 years ago,
Washington,
Boston,
those places were malarial pits,
you know,
but it was public health that got rid of
almost all of that.
So maybe we're all liberal and friendly
because we don't have any infectious
diseases would not be something.
But you know,
our 0.42 correlation,
this was a big study too.
That's a big correlation.
I've never seen a correlation like that.
Especially Laura.
Think about the probability that those
things would be related.
Right.
Is the self report measure of political
belief.
And the other is a public health measure
of disease prevalence and the
probability that those things would be
associated just fight.
You know,
you would just never guess that unless
you came to it the hard way through this
entire logic that we just discussed.
Okay.
So,
so while I was going through this
literature,
I was also reading Hitler's table talk
and Hitler's table talk was a collection
of his spontaneous speeches delivered
over the dinner table from 1939 to 1942
which was roughly the period where the
Nazis were winning the war.
And I noticed something that I haven't
noticed before and what I noticed before
was that Hitler had a very powerful
behavioral immune system.
And so what did that mean?
So you know,
you often hear that the Nazis
annihilated that.
The people that they annihilated because
they were afraid of them,
let's say.
But you then you think about Nazis,
you know,
and you think,
yeah,
maybe fear wasn't there.
Overwhelming characteristic.
You know,
it's some more like brutality or
something like that,
but it's not fear then you don't picture
them trembling in their boots,
you know,
down in the basement or something like
that.
It's not that.
So,
okay.
So anyways,
so I was reading his book and Hitler was
very high in openness by the way,
and very high in orderliness by all
appearances.
And so he,
his vision for the area in race,
so he had this race,
racial theory,
right in the racial theory was that the
proper inhabitants of Europe and
hypothetically the world were blonde,
blue eyed ariens,
which,
which is really not a category and that,
and that it,
the world would be a better place if
they were the dominant group and that
all the other groups were gone.
Also then you think,
well how did Hitler conceptualize this
area in race?
And the answer is he conceptualized it
as a body.
It was the body of it was the body of
the area in race.
And then he conceptualized all the
people that he was out to annihilate as
parasitical invaders.
And so Hitler's metaphor for the Nazi
genocide wasn't fear.
It was discussed.
Okay.
And that's a whole different idea.
Now let me tell you some things about,
oh,
in,
with regards to the orderly part.
Well,
you can just check out the,
okay.
You know,
you're just not going to see a more
orderly gathering.
The people then the picture on the
right,
you know,
at Nuremberg,
which was the prime place where the Nazi
staged their celebrations was the
biggest gathering field ever made in
human history.
People arrange themselves hundreds of
thousands of people into perfect
squares,
everything.
And you remember that Jack boot,
a goose step march and the Hail Hitler.
It's like it's all done an absolutely
perfect sequence and Hitler was a great
admirer of willpower.
He was very happy that he could stand in
the back of his car for eight hours and
keep his hand out like this and he
bathed four times a day.
So what you saw,
what seems to have driven what happened
in Nazi Germany and perhaps is one of
the things that drive right wing
political movements to this day is
heightened sensitivity to discussed.
Now here's how it all got going.
And this is a very brief overview and
many other things happened when Hitler
came to power.
And that was about 1933 thereabouts.
He put into place a variety of public
health initiatives.
And one of them for example,
was he built these vans that had x ray
machines.
And then when he went around everywhere
and screen people for tuberculosis
seemed like a good thing.
Okay.
And then one of the things he did after
that was go on a factory beautification,
a binge,
so to speak.
And so partly that was driven by
openness because he wanted things to be
aesthetically pleasing,
but a lot of it was driven by
orderliness.
And so you're supposed to go into your
factory and sweep the damn thing out and
fix the yard in front of it and plant
some flowers and you know,
make it a look all nice and suburban and
under control.
All right.
So that was,
you know,
maybe still not such a bad idea.
But you know,
when you go into your factory,
while there's rats there and there's
like bugs and things that shouldn't be
there.
And so maybe you think,
well let's get rid of the rats and the
bugs.
And so then you use an insecticide spray
and not spray happened to be Zyklon B,
which we'll return to momentarily while.
So after that,
then Hitler went on a euthanasia kick
and it was sort of like,
you know,
we can get rid of the people who are not
contributing and you know,
who are
not fit to live,
shall we say.
And so that started with euthanasia.
And so it started with people who are in
mental hospitals for example,
and people who had biological
intellectual deficits in such.
And from there it went to people have
the wrong religious tradition.
And from there,
and that was first of all only being
rounded up and herded into council,
let's say,
or first deprived of your property and
of your identity and then rounded up and
put and put into camps.
But what it ended up with was genocidal
and isolation in gas chambers with
Zyklon B.
Right.
And so,
you know,
the Nazis would describe the people that
they were tormenting as parasites and as
insects and as rats.
And that's not fear language,
that's discussed language.
And so it's an appalling
paradox because the behavioral immune
system along with the immune system is
clearly designed to stop people from
dying right in your immune system
distinguishes between you and not you
and you do the same thing at many levels
of behavior,
especially sexually.
And you know who's going to say that
there's anything wrong with that.
It's the same thing when you try to keep
your bathroom cleaned in your kitchen
clean and the city streets cleaned in
all of that and you think,
well that's all for the good.
It's like,
yeah,
but look what happens when that gets out
of control.
You know?
And that's a terrible thing in a sense
because it's,
it's one thing if something that's bad
in and of itself gets out of hand and
then make something really bad,
but it's really a whole different
category of awful.
When something appears to be pretty much
are only for benefit and it gets out of
control and it gets so horrible that it
produces a worse effects,
then the effects that it was designed to
prevent.
I want to just show you a little bit of
a film that goes along with this.
Oh,
there is an example of Nazi order as
well.
So that's at Nuremberg and I need to
explain this picture to you.
So the Nuremberg field was massive.
As I said,
you see those,
those curtains,
those are lights and the lights are the
search lights from the lift Wafa which
was the Nazi air force.
And Hitler would put those up behind him
when he was speaking.
And so then he'd be have a curtain of
lights behind him that stretched up so
high into the sky that you couldn't see
the top of them.
And everybody was organized out there in
they're in their,
ah,
on the marching field.
See there is a good example there.
Look at those people on the left top,
left there.
They're organized in multiple dimensions
simultaneously.
And then on the right you see a
Nuremberg parade ground and there's
hundreds of thousands of people there
and they're all in absolutely perfect
corridors.
These are comments from the,
from Hitler and from the Nazis.
People,
the world will recognize the Jew as
world parasite.
And there will be kind of a time when
there will be one united front of all
people against the Jewish world.
Parasite and humanity will be freed from
the most severe illness from which he
suffered for thousands of years.
So,
and here's,
here's some quotes from Hitler from a
paper called Hitler's ideology embodied
metaphor,
fantasy.
In history,
the state did not power possess the
power to manifest the disease.
The menacing decay of the right was
manifest.
Politicians tinkering around on the
German national body.
So most of the forms of our general
disease,
but blindly ignored the virus.
At the time of the unification,
the inner decay was already in full
swing and the general situation was
deteriorating from year to year.
The station did not grow inwardly
healthier,
but obviously languished more and more.
The symptoms of decay of the prewar
period can be reduced to racial causes.
Anyone who wants to cure this era,
which was inwardly sick and rotten,
must first of all,
sum up the courage to make clear the
causes of this disease.
They think that they must demonstrate
that they are ready for appeasement,
so as to stay that deadly cancerous
ulcer through a policy of moderation.
If this battle should not come,
Germany would decay and at best would
sync to ruin like a rotting corpse.
Well,
you get the idea.
And you know,
it's so interesting to me because you
know,
this is straight psychological research.
Most of it's psychometric,
you know,
and all of a sudden out of that comes
this finding that orderliness is linked
to conservatism and it's linked to the
behavioral immune system.
And poof,
you have a completely new explanation
for what happened with the Nazis.
So,
so that's what happens when orderliness
gets out of hand.
And it's interesting too,
because the Germans are known for their
orderliness,
for their engineering prowess,
you know,
for the organization and cleanliness and
freedom from corruption of their
political state.
And yet this is what happens when it's
taken to an extreme.